this is daniela company for Kitco news
and joining me on the spot today is one
of North America's most successful
entrepreneurs whose kevin O'Leary
chairman of O'Leary funds a 1.5 billion
dollar mutual fund company he's the star
of CBC's dragons then an ABC shark tank
and the author of cold hard truth Kevin
what am I missing from this resume I'm
just having fun trying to scratch out a
living that's what I say just a tad busy
these days so Kevin for our viewers out
there who are new to me refunds tell us
a little bit about your background and
what your company is about you know the
genesis of the company was to manage my
own wealth I was lucky enough to have a
liquidity event a while ago and I sold
the learning company to Mattel was a
large transaction was about 14 of us as
founders we sold it for 4.2 billion
dollars so it was a huge liquidity event
for us and I began to look for managers
to manage my money and I remembered a
story and it really affected me years
ago my mother was born in Montreal
worked at a company called Kitty's togs
and she's to come home and tell my
brother and I because they pay them
every week on Thursday morning she'd
always invest the third of a paycheck
into bail bonds with coupons she'd
always say to me boys never spend the
principal just the interest and never
ever ever ever by a security that
doesn't pay a dividend and you know back
in those days stocks paid higher
dividends than the bond so example you
know bell canada had a six percent yield
on its five-year of paper and bonds the
stock yield at seven to entice people to
take the risk to own an equity and we
got lost somewhere between the 50s and
the 60s and 70s and we actually thought
that it was a good investment to buy a
stock that didn't pay a dividend which
to me is insane so anyways I I wanted to
found a firm on that my mother's basic
concept because you know she died a few
years ago and I was executive for her
state and I looked at the portfolio
which she never shared with anybody but
40 years compounded dividends and bonds
you know seventy-three percent of the
markets returns over the last 40 years
came from dividends not capital
appreciation and she knew that
intuitively so that's how we built the
foundation of ally refunds
we listen to mom we don't own a single
security that doesn't pay a dividend I
will never buy a stock in my life that
doesn't pay a dividend it's not
returning cash to me it's a speculation
and if a manager can't send me cash I'm
not interested right well you mentioned
that often in your book Kevin what's up
what's the typical investor like a
holding refunds you know they're
probably in their 50 60 70 s and even
older their number-one mandate to their
own investment strategies preservation
of wealth secondly its income and lastly
on the hit parade is capital
appreciation the only way we get capital
appreciation is we find companies that
are growing free cash flow I don't
believe in earnings that's mumbo-jumbo
to me I believe in free cash after capex
you tell me how much free cash flow
you're making every quarter it's the
only thing I care about I don't want to
hear anything else because if you're not
you can't lie about cash that's what I
love about cash there's no vision
there's no story there's just cash and
that's what I trust and that's what I
understand so I find companies they're
growing cash i buy their debt there
perhaps their converts their common
shares because they're paid a dividend
and I wait in the weeds I get paid every
single quarter anyway it doesn't pay me
cash not interested what areas of the
world do you like right now where you're
investing you know I look at it very
simplistically I say where's the GDP
growth because that's the rising tide
for any operation at elco a toll road a
consumer goods company you'd rather on
that in a country that has gdp growth
north of three percent so right now you
know I used to be seventy percent
invested in Canada I'm down to less than
twenty-five percent here because we're
not growing we're not growing in the US
I like Brazil India China Asia Cambodia
Thailand they got it cooking over there
they're growing so I'd rather on the
Brazilian telco than any Canadian telco
I mean you look at the the worst returns
and telco are in Canada you can buy a
Brazilian telco that's been a phenomenal
investment in the last five years and
the great thing about these companies
overseas is they're so big now so huge
they're issuing the Securities and US
dollars and I can hedge that back to the
Canadian dollar for next to nothing
so you mentioned China are you liking
the base metals right now like copper I
do but here's the problem with owning
the base metals in my way of looking at
the world with the exception of gold
which I own a five percent waiting of my
net worth in for reasons we'll talk
about later I'd rather own a service
provider that mines copper or provides
utilities to the copper mine that pays
me a dividend I'd rather rather on a
pipeline than the oil that flows in it
because commodities have this nasty
habit of being very volatile they don't
pay you to wait where's my cash where is
my check every month I don't want to
speculate on what copper is going to be
worth next week I'd rather own a company
that's providing high pressure trucks to
copper mines that sends me a five and a
half percent dividend and I do own that
company I get paid every single quarter
cash cash cash cash cash that makes me
feel warm and fuzzy okay so what do you
think of about the gold mining stocks
right now and why maybe they're not
performing in tandem with the price of
gold idiot management the problem is the
management of gold companies can't
control their costs I interview every
gold CEO they come into the CBC or they
come on the Langley exchange I asked the
same question all of them look give me
one reason I should own your stock and
not the gold you mine because I show him
his chart I shown the price of gold and
they are ugly you'd rather own gold
never owned the minor own the gold in
physical gold yeah I oh well here's what
I do I own physical gold for fifty
percent of the positions or two and a
half percent waiting and I use the GL DS
which are an American us pay or US
currency you know product and then I you
know supposedly on the visible go that
way but what I like about the gld is I
can trim my waiting every month so when
it gets over five percent waited I ping
off a few GL DS or i buy in the gld
physical gold I go hug at night it I
think the thesis that many people are
bringing to me now is why not switch out
of gold in the GL DS and by the miners
they've had the the living you know what
pounded out of them they're at the
lowest valuations Visa Visa the
commodity itself and I say they're going
to go lower Wow
I really do because there is no reason
to own every if you look at almost
everyone except the royalty ones their
costs keep going up in every case I say
they're mismanaged I say if a manager
can't control its costs firearm get
somebody else you can because if your
costs of mining the actual ounce keeps
going up why would I ever buy the stock
what give me one reason there's no
mining co you like right now I love them
all I just would never buy their stocks
either great people right but you tell
me one reason I should own the common
give me one reason dividends are
practically nil across the sector you
have huge operational risks you've got
idiot management in the juniors not that
they're bad people I'm just saying the
cold hard truth about investing if you
want exposure to gold by the gold forget
the miners but do you think part of the
problem is there's too many juniors on
the scene for oh it's just a wasteland
it's carnage out there we had the pedic
conference here they were rolling in
like ants into the CBC to get
interviewed I talked to all them till
the story got to be the same like it's
the same start all whoa is me I can't
raise any dough my costs have gone too
high the mine is delayed six months
we're not in operation after a while
it's just the same drone it's boring and
I'm thinking to myself these poor guys
their life must be hell you know the
definition of your bad person on earth
you go to hell and you run a gold mine
okay Kevin Tommy why do you like gold I
like gold because in a way it's a
stabilizer it's an insurance policy you
know I listen to all the gold pundits
and they're always wrong as far as I'm
concerned it's possible to time the
moves I've owned gold for decades and I
simply have a five percent waiting I
look at it quarterly when it becomes
more than five percent I sell into the
strength and when it weakens i buy into
the weakness it's just a stabilizer you
know I'm not one of those guys that's
going to go to forty percent waiting and
gold I don't believe the hyperinflation
story it hasn't happened gold is popular
for a whole host of reasons and five
percent seems to be enough it's worked
for me in portfolio management it's the
only security I own that doesn't pay a
deal so Kevin I guess do you not care if
gold goes to two thousand or five
those announcers still going to buy gold
yeah I don't care like let it let it run
i'll be selling into that strength even
a five percent waiting you know what
I've learned I'm an old crusty investor
when everybody's saying you got to own
it you should be selling it because when
it corrects it doesn't touch the sides
on the way down so I simply say five
percent is good for me some people like
at ten fifteen percent waiting I'm a
five percent guy and I'm disciplined
about it I hope it runs to 5000 I don't
care i'll be selling selling selling
selling and selling all the way up
keeping it five percent and when it
corrects back down in two thousand we
buying it in it's fun that's the way you
should work with gold never get so
caught up that you take all your
dividend yielding securities that are
also a hedge against inflation and put
it into a commodity like gold what do
you think of people who say we should go
back to a gold standard that's
unnecessary we're in a global economy
now you know you think about what's
happened with currencies here's my
strategy with that I simply say look if
I'm domiciled in the country where I pay
taxes which for me right now is Canada I
have fifty percent of my cash in
canadian dollars then I diversified
through every other currency I own US
dollars I've got a twenty percent
waiting there i own swiss francs i own
euros i don't need the Aussie dollar
because it's too correlated to the
canadian and i sit and wait you know
people are trying to tell me let's FX
here let's FX there nobody can make
money and FX trading you blow up when
you try and do that so just own a basket
of currencies and then you know you
don't know who's going to raise rates
first and what the deltas are going to
be but you're protected that way
speaking of currencies do you think
we'll see a shift in a global reserve
currency one day I think in my lifetime
which I hope is a lot of years left we
will see the Chinese wanted over I I
just look at my investments in that
country they're volatile but the
performance and the growth metrics are
fantastic I can sense the cash moving
out of North America old and fat and
slow growth where the Romans now and
then I look at where I'm making all my
money it's all happening in Brazil India
China so scale the Chinese economy is
going to overtake North America during
my lifetime a lot of people are alluding
to the
now Kevin so yeah yeah look there's
nothing look when you have tax policy
and confusion and I think you know the
American economy was burdened by being
the policeman of the world they've just
figured out that doesn't work but
they're trillions of dollars in debt I
don't think you can see the Americans
jump into the next war anytime soon it's
just too expensive that whole experience
in the last seven years has been
horrible we as Canadians should also
look at that example and say let's take
care of our own cooking here let's make
sure that we pay down our debt the most
mismanaged province in Canada right now
is Ontario this governments in chaos it
doesn't know what it's doing it's
getting them back oh I mean it's on its
way to being to Quebec I mean the
taxation here was on its way to being
competitive you want a twenty-five
percent tax rate and the government here
is stalled the declines in the
provincial taxes they've raised a super
tax on the rich which never works by the
way never they're going to have less tax
revenue than they started they're so
dumb that way that's a huge mistake you
think the rich are stupid they're just
going to defer their income or take it
right out of the province they'll leave
it's a very bad strategy the British
tried it and they lost revenues if we
raise the fifty percent now they're
dropping it down again so let's look at
the u.s. a second you think that we'll
see more money printing there will be
see a qe3 perhaps I think in a way qe3
will happen because I look at some just
fundamental issues that what we needed
to see was 400,000 jobs a month we're
nowhere near there were at least thirty
three percent less than that that's just
a break-even stop unemployment but it's
the housing that has me nervous it
refuses to come back and you just looked
at last week's price you learn numbers
and they're down even in consider these
like Boston you know Miami's were
covering a little bit but the major
centers are still anemic and that's a
problem because until Americans feel
that the core asset their home has
stabilized they're not going to have the
animal spirits and they're going to
continue to have less buying power so
it's a problem I'm not calling for
collapse of the US markets in fact
they're doing very well because the SP
is fifty two percent of its sales
outside of north america but the core
underlying growth of america is going to
be sub three percent for a couple of
years and maybe longer all right come on
let's just get back to your book a
session
and you say you really know whether
you're born to be an entrepreneur or an
employee right so how did you know you
know I tried working for somebody when
it's very young and they fired me an ice
cream right and it was a very very
profoundly affected me profoundly and I
just said I'm never working for anybody
again it doesn't mean your life is
easier in fact you give up you have to
have a lot of sacrifices in on the road
to success and a lot of failures along
the way I just find it a more
interesting way to spend your time and I
really believe in this concept of money
buys freedom and so you know I think
every it's a very noble pursuit for some
percentage of the people out there but
not for everybody because you have to
sacrifice a lot for the period that
you're working on your business and not
everybody wants to do that and I think
you find that in your own you start down
that path and if it's too much of a
sacrifice you revert back to being an
employee which is it's very noble to do
that too but it's not the same thing it
takes a long time to set yourself free
working for somebody else in your book
you also say when you're investing you
should have an element of fear in there
you should make the assumption when you
make an investment there's some
probability you lose it it'll go to zero
and that's why you need to have you know
a reserve like a back-up plan some cash
set aside that if everything blows up
you're okay I find it extraordinary when
people make their first you know
liquidity event and they have some
capital that they blow it all again that
is the biggest mistake you've got to
take a nut even if it stays in cash or
it's a very very liquid safe security to
say that I don't touch it goes back to
what my mother taught me spend the
interest never the principal I mean look
you know I make a lot of crazy
investments I don't touch the principal
what investments are you liking today
I'm liking very simple deals where I can
understand the business model give you
an example how boring and simple and how
successful it can be this is from shark
tank you know I do I look at a lot of
deals on shark tank and on Dragon's Den
because I invest five percent of my net
worth every year in venture deals so I
used to have to go find
now they come to rain I've got two
platforms to work on this is a shark
tank deal so Oprah has a hairdresser
interesting guy he's uh his hobby was t
this teen you drink and he became what's
called a nose he had a certain skill to
be able to smell salon teez blend them
one day he gives couple years ago a cup
of tea to Oprah well he's doing her hair
and she sips it and says his best to
have ever had she goes on the show half
an hour later and says this tea called
Talbot ease is the best tea I've ever
had he gets orders the next day for five
hundred thousand dollars you know the
Oprah effect you've heard of it right he
can't finance that so he comes on shark
tank and he's looking for $250,000 and I
agreed to buy thirty five percent of the
company for that I love tea it's so
simple gets on Oprah 500,000 orders and
even Marcus all kinds of individuals
bordering on the Internet simple t
orders cash flow right while we're in
the middle of doing the deal the show
airs and Gemma juice a public company
says we want to be in the tea business
we love this story we love the brand I
want to buy the company I have any
written a check yet and bang the deals
done Wow yes wow that's the kind of deal
i like because it was simple it's not a
complicated text story it's tea tea with
a brand now you go into a Jamba Juice
anywhere in North America that's my
Talbot tease that's right isn't that
wonderful is wonderful that's why you
are well that's why i am is but you know
i look at it this way the simple deals
are the ones you make money on so i take
that cash back I redeploy it so I like
simple stories with revenue attached to
them you know the high-tech stuff I came
out of that market it's so complicated
so much can go wrong so i just love
deals where they see an easy path to
revenue all right Kevin finally if you
have some final thoughts for investors
watching out there diversification is
the only free lunch and investing and I
see this happen so many times here's my
basic lesson that I've learned that I
never vary from and this works trust me
it works never more than five percent of
your poor
folio in anyone named no matter how
great the story is if it's the next
nortel if it's the next rim who cares
five percent max waiting for me usually
it's two and a half to three percent I
never let a stock get bigger than that
in my portfolio I sell into the strength
all the time secondly never ever ever
more than twenty percent anyone sector
so if you love gold you just can't get
past twenty percent of your net worth in
gold or energy or any other sector or
financial services so good sectoral
diversification is crucial and finally
for me I'm over sixty percent waited in
debt now versus equity not government
debt not Treasury bonds but corporate
debt remember that a BB or triple V bond
is serviced before they pay the dividend
on a common stock so I like to own right
up the balance sheet so I own a lot of
preface converts senior debt floating
rate notes I love that stuff because
when they get upgraded like a capital
appreciation meanwhile I get a check the
key to life is the check coming in it's
the cash if you always always always
look at the free cash flow this will
keep you safe because the only friend
you're going to have when you're old and
crusty is not your dog not your kids
it's the cash in the bank that's still
going to love you Kevin thank you so
much no problem and thank you for
watching this edition of on the spot you
can email me as always that news feed
back at kipp coked up
you